ccsd is putting plans in place to ensure
that both teachers and students are safe
when returning to school
thanks for joining us i'm denise feldas
and i'm brian loftis in a little more
than two weeks
pre-k right through third grade students
will transition to a hybrid learning
model
tonight the district reached agreements
with local unions again focused on staff
and student safety
sasha loftis has been combing through
all of those details and joins us now
from the newsroom with more
sasha
denise and brian this nearly 3 million
dollar agreement
will address safety concerns across the
district and provide things like masks
and disinfectant
for staff all across different campuses
as they start to reopen
in preparation for that hybrid learning
on march
1st now this plan includes personal
protective equipment for
every employee including face coverings
and disinfectant
each employee will also be required to
undergo daily symptom
screening and mandatory covid19 testing
every month
the new agreement also provides
additional compensation for any
any extra duties performed for some
staff if an employee
does test positive they have the option
to work from home if possible
and can return in person after a
negative test
now there were more than 100 pages of
public comments
during this meeting now a lot asks for
sports to be brought back for students
now governor sisselak actually mentioned
that as well today
saying that school bringing kids back to
campus is really the main priority there
and then they will address sports and
that coming back afterward
for now reporting live in the newsroom
tonight sasha loftis 8 news now